Solve The Transfer Section of a
Plant Shows Following Anatomical Features Number
One You are given
Large Number of Scattered Bundles Surrounded by
Bundle Sheet Cells Number Two Large Conspicuous
As Parenchyma As Ground Tissue
Is Conspicuous As These Are Not Conspicuous Pay Attention
Vascular Bundles Are  We are
talking about the category of Conjunctions plant.
Yes, the answer to all is absolutely correct. I think it
is your monocot stem. Phloem parenchyma is
absent. Yes ma'am. Conjunctions are closed. Yes
ma'am. A lot of large ground tissue is found. Yes ma'am and large number.  Of
scattered bundles are found in your Yes ma'am
answer is option number D